according to nissan it engineered the
second generation of the note in europe
for europe technical goodies are packed
into plenty in the sporty hatch to
guarantee carefree city driving
it's testing hard today it's based on
the renault clio's platform says our car
tester carla siemens
visually it strikes a decidedly new note
the contours swing down under the grille
an emblem flanked by multi-reflector
headlights
the big-eyed daytime running lights
blend the note and almost playful air
the elegant flowing contours and the
windows swept up toward the rear give it
a dynamic sporty look
the all-round monitor works with four
separate cameras one in front one behind
and two on the sides
there are blind spot and lane departure
warning systems plus another assist that
spots moving objects when reversing
together they comprise nissan's very own
degree safety shield
and how does nissan's new city car
perform on the road
karola describes it as small nimble and
easy to drive with the instruments all
neatly arranged on the downside she has
the feeling that the note doesn't have a
lot of pickup putting the pedal to the
metal doesn't do much
but the nissan note does well enough
driving around town three engines are
available two gasoline powered and one
diesel
this model puts out 59 kilowatts of
power and fuel consumption is rated at
4.7 liters per hundred kilometers it can
zip along country highways at a top
speed of 170 kilometers per hour
the interior emphasizes ease of
operation and simplicity
a nice detail is the eco button
pressing it brings up the ecometer in
the speedometer it's supposed to
motivate the driver to drive more fuel
consciously
the note's rear bench has sufficient
room for passengers and a bit of extra
cargo but the bags can just as easily go
into the trunk the double decker
configuration can expand the storage
volume from 325 to 411 leaders
sums up the nissan note as a dependable
and robust city run around that
definitely lives up to the compact car
idea the interior could have stood a few
improvements here and there mostly in
the instrument panel she's not entirely
happy with the materials and workmanship
the prevalence of hard plastic isn't to
her taste
in terms of safety though the note is an
innovator the safety shield however only
enters the picture with the mid-range
equipment levels and costs around 1200
euros extra